>>> RIGHT NOW, CANADA IS BRACING
FOR WHAT COULD BE THE STRONGEST
STORM TO HIT THE EAST.
HURRICANE FIONA EXPECTED TO MAKE
LANDFALL TOMORROW AND SHOWING
LITTLE SIGNS OF EASING UP.
CLIMATE CHANGE IS FUELING MORE
FREQUENT, MORE DRASTIC WEATHER
EVENTS AROUND THE WORLD AND
HIGHLIGHTING BIG WEALTHY
COMPANIES TO ADDRESS THE CLIMATE
CRISIS.
SALESFORCE CEO MARC BENIOFF
JOINED US TO TALK ABOUT THIS AND
SAID THE PLANET IS A KEY STAKE
HOLDER.
I'D LIKE TO DIVE INTO CLIMATE
CHANGE WITH YOU.
THE U.N. SAYS THE CLIMATE IMPACT
IS HEADING INTO AN UNCHARTED
TERRITORY OF DESTRUCTION.
THAT'S WHAT THE UNITED NATIONS
SAYS.
HOW WORRIED ARE YOU?
>> WE CAN USE BUSINESSES OR
PLATFORMS FOR CHANGE.
WE CAN ADDRESS THESE PROBLEMS.
WE KNOW WHAT THEY ARE.
IN REGARDS TO CLIMATE CHANGE,
IT'S ABOUT LOWERING EMISSIONS.
IT'S ABOUT ALL OF US GOING NET
ZERO.
IT'S ALSO ABOUT PLANTING A
TRILLION TREES, WHICH IS WHY YOU
SEE SO MANY TREES HERE.
WE HAVE A PROGRAM TO PLANT A
TRILLION TREES BY 2030 BECAUSE
THAT'S 200 GIGATON OF CARBON
STORAGE.
ENTREPRENEURS LIKE ME FOCUSED ON
THE ENVIRONMENT BUILDING AMAZING
COMPANIES AND TECHNOLOGIES AND
LAUNCHING HERE AT THE SHOW THIS
NET ZERO MARKETPLACE SO
ENTREPRENEURS CAN SHOW OUR
CUSTOMERS, HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF CUSTOMERS THE SOLUTIONS THEY
HAVE TO GO NET ZERO.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE PROFIT DRIVEN
BUSINESSES IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR
CAN PUT THE ENVIRONMENT FIRST?
YOU SAID THE PLANET IS A KEY
STAKE HOLDER WITHOUT SAF CRIFICG
PROFIT FOR KEY SHAREHOLDERS.
>> THAT'S WHY I GET OUT OF BED
EVERY MORNING.
SALESFORCE IS WELL DO OVER $6
BILLION IN PROFIT AND MARGINS
OVER 20%.
WE JUST RAISED OUR MARGIN
GUIDANCE TO 25% FOR WHERE WE'RE
GOING WHEN WE ACHIEVE $50
BILLION IN REVENUE IN 2026 AND
WE CAN DO IT ALL.
WE CAN HAVE SUPER HIGH REVENUE,
SUPER HIGH PROFIT, SUPER HIGH
CASH FLOW AND WE CAN MANAGE FOR
ALL STAKE HOLDERS.
THAT MEANS WE'RE MANAGING FOR
EMPLOYEES, CUSTOMERS,
COMMUNITIES, OUR HOMELESS AND
YES, THE PLANET IS A KEY STAKE
HOLDER, AS WELL.
>> OKAY.
SO THAT MAKES ME THINK OF
PATGONIA JUST LITERALLY GAVE THE
COMPANY TO THE EARTH WRITING
EARTH IS THE ONLY SHAREHOLDER.
I GET THAT YOU CAN'T DO THAT.
YOU'RE A PUBLIC COMPANY BUT
SHOULD MORE PRIVATE COMPANIES DO
THAT?
>> I THINK THERE IS MANY THINGS
MANY DIFFERENT COMPANIES CAN DO.
I'M VERY INSPIRED BY THE FOUNDER
OF PATGONIA LIKE A LOT OF US
AAR
ARE.
I THINK WE CAN ALL DO SOMETHING.
>> MARC IN AN INTERVIEW THIS
WEEK YOU TALKED ABOUT THE
ECONOMY AND SAID THE RECESSION.
I WANT TO GET MY HEAD AROUND
WHERE YOU THINK WE ARE.
DO YOU THINK THE U.S. IS IN OR
VERY CLOSE TO RECESSION?
>> I THINK IT'S MANY ECONOMIES
NOW.
I WAS JUST IN JAPAN.
THAT'S ONE ECONOMY.
THEY'RE EXPERIENCING A HIGHLY
DEFLATED CURRENCY.
I WAS IN EUROPE, AS WELL.
THEIR CURRENCY IS DEFLPLAFLATIN
THEY'RE GOING INTO RECESSION.
I WOULDN'T SAY THE UNITED STATES
IS IN RECESSION TODAY.
>> OKAY.
SO LET ME MOVE ON FROM THERE.
SALESFORCE EMPLOYS PEOPLE ALL
OVER THE COUNTRY AND AFTER THE
SUPREME COURT OVERTURNED ROE
VERSUS WADE YOU CAME OUT AND
SAID SALESFORCE WILL RELOCATE
EMPLOYEES WHEREVER THEY FEEL
MOST COMFORTABLE GIVEN THIS NEW
ENVIRONMENT.
HAVE YOU SEEN PEOPLE TAKE UP
THAT?
>> POPPY, THIS IS NOT OUR FIRST
CONSERVATION WHAT IS A CEO'S
ROLE IN POLITICAL ISSUES.
WHAT DO WE DO WHEN IT COMES TO
ACTUALLY MAKING SOMETHING
HAPPEN.
THE NUMBER ONE THING IS WE MUST
HAVE EMPLOYEES BACK.
YOU KNOW AND I KNOW WE'RE
DEALING WITH A SERIES OF CRAZY
PRESIDENTS, CRAZY GOVERNORS.
CRAZY MAJORS, ALL OVER THE WORLD
AND EVERY COUNTRY AND EVERY CITY
AND EVERY STATE.
THE NUMBER ONE THING I CAN DO IS
LET MY EMPLOYEES KNOW I'M HERE
FOR THEM AND WILL 100% SUPPORT
THEM AND IF THEY'RE NOT HAPPY
WHERE THEY ARE, YOU'RE RIGHT.
>> WHO IS CRAZY?
>> I'M TALKING ABOUT ALL OF THE
SITUATIONS I'VE HAD TO GO
THROUGH OVER THE LAST DECADE
ESPECIALLY WHERE OUR EMPLOYEES
WILL CONTACT ME AND SAY
SOMETHING JUST IS NOT RIGHT.
YOU KNOW THE STORY FOR EXAMPLE
IN INDIANA.
WE'RE THE LARGEST TECH EMPLOYER
>> I WAS GOING TO BRING UP
INDIANA BECAUSE MARC, FOR PEOPLE
IN 2013 YOU THREATENED NOT JUST
TO RELOCATE EMPLOYEES.
IN 2015 YOU THREATENED TO PULL
ALL OF SALESFORCE OUT OF INDIANA
BECAUSE OF A LAW THAT WOULD
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST LGBTQ
PEOPLE AND YOU WON THE FIGHT AND
THEY DIDN'T END UP ENACTING THAT
LAW.
IS THAT SOMETHING YOU'RE
CONSIDERING NOW IN STATES
RESTRICTING ABORTION OR OUT
LAWING ABORTION TO NOT JUST
OFFER TO RELOCATE PEOPLE BUT
PULL RESOURCES?
>> WE ACTUALLY JUST SAID IF YOU
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST OUR
EMPLOYEES, WE WON'T BE ABLE TO
SET UP SHOP THERE.
WHEN WE SAID THAT, 200 OTHER
COMPANIES THE NEXT DAY, THE
LARGEST COMPANIES IN THE UNITED
STATES SAID WE AGREE.
WE HAVE TO SUPPORT LGBTQ
COMMUNITIES AS WELL.
WE HAVE TO BE FOR EQUALITY, WE
HAVE TO BE FOR DIGNITY.
WE HAVE TO BE FOR EQUALITY AND
DIGNITY OF EVERY HUMAN BEING AND
IF YOU'RE NOT FOR EQUALITY AND
DIGNITY, THIS IS NOT SOMETHING
WE CAN WORK WITH AND WE'LL HAVE
TO EXIT YOUR CITY OR STATE AS WE
HAVE IN MANY PLACES.
>> TWITTER.
THERE WAS A DAY WHEN YOU WANTED
TO BUY TWITTER.
OKAY?
AND YOU WRITE ABOUT IT JUST
SO -- IT'S SO FASCINATING HOW
YOU WRITE ABOUT IT IN YOUR BOOK
AND YOU WROTE THE MORE PEOPLE
TOLD ME I WAS CRAZY, THE MORE MY
ARTER FOR THE IDEA GREW.
YOU DIDN'T BUY TWITTER AND I
WONDER WHAT YOU SEE NOW IN THE
BATTLE BETWEEN TWITTER AND ELON
MUSK.
>> I'M NOT REALLY FOLLOWING THE
BATTLE.
I ALWAYS HAD A HUGE VISION FOR
TWITTER.
IT'S ONE OF THE MOST EXCITING
APPLICATIONS IN THE WORLD.
I'VE ALWAYS THOUGHT TWITTER
COULD BE AN OPERATING SYSTEM.
I ALWAYS THOUGHT TWITTER COULD
BE A RECEPTACLE FOR APPLICATIONS
WHEN I LOOK AT THE FRAMES INSIDE
THE TEXT FIELDS, I ASK MYSELF
WOW, WHY CAN'T THOSE BE APPS?
WHY CAN'T THERE BE APP STORES?
WHY CAN'T WE HAVE SOMETHING TO
CREATE MORE USER ENGAGEMENT BUT
WHEN I WENT TO BUY TWITTER AND
HAVING THE CONVERSATIONS, ALL OF
MY SHAREHOLDERS CAME AND SAID
YOU CAN STOP THAT NOW.
YOU WON'T PURSUE THIS VISION.
IT'S HARD FOR ME BECAUSE I'M A
VISIONARY.
I'LL GET THINGS IN MY HEAD AND
FOR SOMEBODY TO TELL ME YOU MAY
HAVE THE VISION IN YOUR HEAD BUT
YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO EXECUTE
THIS VISION.
IT WAS A TOUGH MOMENT FOR ME.
>> BUT MARC, I HAVE TO TELL YOU
LISTENING TO YOUR ANSWER, YOU
SOUND TO ME LIKE SOMEONE WHO
MIGHT STILL WANT TO BUY TWITTER.
>> POPPY, THAT WILL NEVER
HAPPEN.
JUST TALK TO MY INVESTORS.
THEY WILL MAKE IT VERY CRYSTAL
CLEAR TO YOU.
>> WHAT IF IT WAS UP TO YOU?
WOULD YOU BUY TWITTER TODAY MARC
IF IT WAS UP TO YOU?
>> ABSOLUTELY IF IT WAS JUST ME
AND MY POCKETBOOK, IT'S THE
GREATEST, MOST UNREALIZED, MOST
UNMONETIZED BRAND IN THE
TECHNICAL INDUSTRY AND IT'S AN
AMAZING COMPANY, AMAZING BRAND,
AMAZING PLATFORM AND CAN DO
INCREDIBLE THINGS FOR THE FUTURE
AND I HAVE ALWAYS BEEN IN LOVE
WITH THE PRODUCT.
I USE IT EVERY DAY.
AND I BELIEVE VERY STRONGLY THAT
THIS HAS GOT STILL A HUGE AMOUNT
OF POTENTIAL AHEAD.
>> EVEN GIVEN THE -- I MEAN, A,
YOU DON'T THINK IT HAS THE BOT
PROBLEM THAT E LISTLON MUSK THIT
HAS?
>> I'M SURE THERE IS MANY PARTS
OF THE PLATFORM THAT MAY OR MAY
NOT BE EXACTLY OPTIMAL LIKE ALL
SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES.
>> EVEN AFTER THIS WHISTLE
BLOWER CAME OUT WITH THE
WARNINGS ABOUT DATA PRIVACY
CONCERNS AND SECURITY POTENTIAL,
REACHBILITY?
YOU STILL WANT IT?
MARC BENIOFF STILL WANTS
TWITTER.
>> I'M TELLING YOU MY INVESTORS
WILL NEVER LET ME BUY TWITTER.
I'LL NEVER BUY TWITTER.
BECAUSE I WANT SOMETHING DOESN'T
MEAN I'LL HAVE IT.
IT'S A LOT LIKE I WOULD LIKE TO
GO HAVE A SUNDAE WITH THREE
SCOOPS OF ICE CREAM, WHIPPED
CREAM AND A CHERRY BUT I'M NOT
GOING TO HAVE IT.
>> TWITTER IS AN ICE CREAM
SUNDAY.
>> I GUESS IF YOU ASK MARK
BUNB
BENIOFF, HE WON'T HAVE TWITTER.
IT'S RARE.